yes it's fall yes it's Oscar season what
gets you an Oscar better than cancer
that sounded a little weird though
fifty-fifty
alright no I had heard great things
about 5050 everyone has loved 5050 that
I've talked to so 5050 Stars Joseph
gordon-levitt you know he's a nice guy
he keeps in shape and he gets diagnosed
with cancer which for me is no surprise
because the first scene you see he's
running he's jogging he's exercising and
I was looking around going cloudy skies
water that looks like Seattle well on
the whole that takes place in Seattle
and we all get cancer up here it's crazy
and so the movies pretty much him just
dealing with it hence the title 50-50
because the mortality rate for the
cancer that he has is 50% wouldn't know
in fact about me is cancer just scares
the out of me I don't know what it
is when I was 11 years old just one day
I woke up and I was like the most
frightening thing on earth is cancer
freaks me out I don't exist cuz it could
happen to anyone I mean take Joseph
gordon-levitt in this movie no real
reason he should have cancer but he has
cancer now and so when dealing with this
cancer he has his best friend Seth Rogen
I like Seth Rogen a lot in this movie
Seth Rogen's kind of hit-and-miss for me
either he's gonna be really hilarious
I'm just gonna love him or he's gonna
take it overboard and get so obnoxious
that you're gonna hate him this one he
was hilarious until he got a little
obnoxious than you like him again
however the weird thing was he was the
guy he was like the cool charming friend
that got phone numbers from chicks
wasn't the joke and knocked up that that
guy just looks like he could not get
Katherine Heigl so why does he get
chicks in 50/50 who were hotter than
Katherine Heigl that does make any sense
to me but I really liked him I like the
contrast between him and Joseph
gordon-levitt's character I mean they're
nothing alike so I thought it worked
they got the yin and yang thing going on
like there's this one scene I'm not
gonna ruin the scene for you but he sees
something in art gallery how he handles
that situation is like exactly how I
would handle that situation so I was
like I like that guy he is awesome but
Joseph gordon-levitt at first he's
really closed off he doesn't want to
talk about the cancer he doesn't want to
say that you know he's having a tough
time dealing with he just wants to be
like I'm fine let's just move on he
talks to his therapist who isn't
actually a doctor yeah she's like 24
years old she's going for her doctorate
so this is like the learning curve for
her and at first he's like great I got a
doctor that's not a doctor that's just
as special but I liked how it let her
and him connect you know and they build
this kind of romance but not a romance
it's like an unspoken romance whatever
it was I liked it I liked her a lot
she's just really cute I know I'm the
guy
I review movies I'm always like oh yeah
you know that chick is hot I always
point that out in my reviews but this
chick was like really cute I would lie
would date her and I have never said
that in her review ever and it was such
a serious subject I just think it's
important to laugh the movie did that
really well I like that very rarely will
I go from laughing to wanting to cry
back to laughing it was just really good
it was a really good movie like he gets
this dog it's named Skeletor it's ex
rice dog I don't know if it's really
cracked skinny or like really cut or
both it looks like something out of the
new phyrexia block it looks horrible and
if you don't know what new phyrexia is
it's fine you're not supposed to know
what new phyrexia is in fact don't
google it right now because if you find
out that I know what new phyrexia is my
reputations it's it's gone you'll know
how nerdy I actually am but I hate new
phyrexia poison counters really no get
out of here with that upon all the
hype that 50/50 already had I was
surprised as to how much I really liked
the movie it's well written it's well
directed as well acted so I gotta say
50/50 is awesome tacular but as for you
guys I'm not gonna ask you a cancer
question anything like that that just
sounds weird but think of the entire
year what's the movie that surprised you
this year whatever it is comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
you